MAX SALTONSTALL: Millions
of people in New York City
means billions of
events every day.
Join us as we talk with New York
City Cyber Command about what
these events are, why it's
important to track them,
and how they built
a scalable system
to protect all of the people in
New York City on this episode
of "Stack Chat."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for joining
us today, Noam.
Can you tell us a little bit
about what New York City Cyber
Command does?
NOAM DOROGOYER: Sure.
Thanks for having us.
So New York City Cyber
Command is an organization
that is responsible for
preventing, detecting,
responding, and
recovering to any threats
to our city systems.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's
a pretty big mandate.
And you've got a
lot of information
coming in every day.
Can you tell me how
you built a pipeline
to process all of that data?
NOAM DOROGOYER: We have
tons of log sources.
I think we're
approaching 20 now,
and we'll have more by the day.
So we have on cloud and on prem.
And the way we
split things up is
that, for on prem log sources,
we use the syslog-ng protocol.
And we use it to enrich
all logs with metadata,
whether it be IPs, or
timestamps, and so on.
For on-cloud, we use
Google's Cloud Functions
to perform a similar function.
So once we get that
data, we can output
it using Google's Pub/Sub.
And we have an application
called Flow Control
that inputs all this data.
And it runs on Google's
Data Flow and Apache Beam
in order to remove all corrupt,
meaningless, or incomplete data
so further down the pipeline,
we don't have to handle it,
and we don't have to
distract from the parsers.
So once that's complete,
we, once again,
use Google's Pub/Sub to
now take all our logs
into our main piece of
logic, which is the parsers.
So for every single log, we
have a different set of code,
whether it's separated by
a bunch of mumbo jumbo,
or comma separated, and so on.
Now we can make it into
meaningful data and something
that's queriable by
our security analysts.
And the best place for
that would be BigQuery.
Once it's in BigQuery, we can
start taking all our data,
and applying machine
learning algorithms,
outputting it into dashboards,
or just having something
as simple as having our security
analysts query it and find
something dangerous or
maybe a hacking attempt.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So if you could
go back and tell past Noam what
to do from the
beginning, what lesson
would you give yourself to
make this whole process easier?
NOAM DOROGOYER: Google
Pub/Sub is unordered.
And as a result, that
made it so that we
had to add a lot of additional
complex logic later on in order
to reassemble some of our data.
Our log sources are split up.
And sometimes a message
might come in now,
and then the remainder
of that message
might come 20 minutes
later, a couple hours later,
or tomorrow.
And when messages
aren't ordered,
we don't really know when
something is necessarily
tied into another message.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Tell me a little bit
about what's coming next.
What new evolutions
are you excited
about for this pipeline?
NOAM DOROGOYER: Right.
So we have three approaches.
So firstly, we want to expand
on the machine learning
algorithms.
We have a supervised and
unsupervised application
that is essentially
in alpha right now.
We want to finish
it, and we want
to have it outputting
meaningful results.
Then they want to
start spreading
our pipeline to other cities.
We want to maybe write some
white papers or some research
topics, and have them create
a similar secure space that we
have.
And finally, we want
to expand to sim space.
Right now, we're creating a
simulation environment that
is nearly identical to our own.
And we can use that to
gather training data
and model some of
the attacks that are
coming against city systems.
MAX SALTONSTALL: It's great
to know that you and your team
are working hard to
keep us all safe.
Thank you very much.
NOAM DOROGOYER: Thank you.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Interested in checking out
Apache Beam and Data Flow?
Get started with some templates
to get up and running quickly.
Thanks for watching.
And make sure to subscribe
for more great Google Cloud
Platform content.
We'll see you on the next
episode of "Stack Chat."
[MUSIC PLAYING]